souvent il arrive aussi qu'ils soient
propriétaires ou qu'il ne soit pas quand
ils sont sur les cinquante pas
géométriques est dans une situation
d'occupant sans titre bon ils ne sont
pas non plus propriétaire mans va dire
qu'ils sont quasi propriétaire et c'est
un défi un des éléments de la réflexion
que nous avons menée c'est vrai
s'agissant présent des personnes âgées
très souvent elles se retrouvaient quasi
propriétaires ne paient pas de loyer et
aux traumatismes justement de la
relocalisation du déplacement s'ajouter
des problématiques économiques quand on
connaît la modicité quelquefois des
pensions de retraite qui sont servis à
nos personnes âgées dont ces éléments
étaient prises en compte et l'ingénierie
financière viendra aussi de manière à ce
que voudrait par exemple des logements
évolutifs sociaux les mains de deux
manières justement à avoir un
accompagnement social cela s'appelle de
la mettrie faiseuse sociale urbaine des
mousses qui permettra justement de de
régler ce type de problème à construire
des conséquences économiques et c'est
donc vraiment tout cela et penser de
manière à ce que les modalités de
construction ne soit pas très coûteuse
qu'elle soit efficace et qu'elle soit
surtout adapté aux réalités sociales de
notre population